[Música]
y crear y trascender se trata de dos
impulsos inherentes al ser humano puede
que quieras creer que dios no los dio al
momento de la creación cuando nos hizo a
su imagen y semejanza o puede que
prefieras creer que en algún punto de la
evolución del ser humano cambia su
prioridad de sobrevivir a trascender en
cualquiera de los dos formas estamos en
un punto clave de la historia en este
punto de inflexión en el cual el ser
humano quiere crear algo a su imagen y
semejanza
ese hijo prodigio para enseñarle lo que
es bello bueno y verdadero la tecnología
es aquello que nos hizo pasar de
animales a dioses sin duda alguna la
cúspide de la inteligencia humana
gracias a la tecnología es que somos
capaces de hacer frente a las guerras la
hambruna y las plagas como nunca antes
la tecnología en nuestra novena sinfonía
nuestra venus de milo nuestra noche
estrellada la tecnología y más en
específico la inteligencia artificial es
ese hijo prodigio hecho nuestra imagen y
semejanza por supuesto más listo más
rápido y mejor que nosotros en todos los
aspectos
es arte alguna vez dijo que todo lo que
creamos no es otra cosa más que un
intento desesperado para venir a
subsanar nuestras deficiencias
pongamos por ejemplo a da vinci cuando
da vinci pintó la gioconda no nada más
lo hizo para ilustrar en un lienzo la
belleza de lisa gherardini sino también
para que a diferencia de él su obra
pudiese ser perfecta inmortal y
atemporal el ser humano encuentra en la
inteligencia artificial el complemento
perfecto para sus deficiencias una forma
buenísima de burlar el olvido y la
mortalidad encuentra en la inteligencia
artificial ese hijo prodigio hecho a su
imagen y semejanza
pero estamos en lo correcto al crear
algo más listo más capaz y mejor que
nosotros en todos los aspectos
actualmente hay un debate abierto sobre
si la inteligencia artificial debería de
ser regulada o no por un lado tenemos a
gente que muy positiva como mark
zuckenberg el creador de facebook
diciendo que no se va a cansar de
enumerar todas las ventajas que puede
traer consigo tener una súper
inteligencia que esté por encima de
nosotros pero por otro lado tenemos a
gente muy negativa como hilo en más que
el creador de tesla y space sex diciendo
que no se va a cansar pero de sonar la
alarma porque estamos frente a algo más
peligroso que todo el armamento nuclear
existente
pero este debate no es exclusivo de los
millonarios de silicon valley realmente
si tuviese que resumirlo sería en las
opiniones de gary bush contra las de
nick bostróm poblado tenemos a gary bus
que está a favor de la inteligencia
artificial y dice que es normal sentir
miedo
qué es normal porque estamos en un punto
de la historia en donde nos damos cuenta
de las limitantes de nuestros cuerpos y
nuestras mentes y es precisamente por
eso que creamos máquinas exquisitas
complejas y llenas de gracia que van a
mejorar nuestras vidas más allá de lo
imaginable pero por otro lado tenemos a
nick bostróm diciendo que precisamente
esas mismas máquinas complejas
exquisitas y llenas de gracia
representan un peligro para el mundo tal
y como lo conocemos
boston basa su teoría en el cerebro
humano este regalo de la biología es la
razón por la cual nosotros estamos por
sobre el resto de las especies es por la
cual somos el depredador ápex y somos el
único animal que no se reconoce como tal
si tomamos el cerebro y lo
perfeccionamos haciendo un volumen 2
quitándole todos los bloqueos y todas
las barreras bioquímicas con las que
cuenta lo llevamos a una tablilla
conductora podríamos afirmar casi sin
lugar a dudas que nuestro destino
dependería de la inteligencia artificial
como el destino de los gorilas depende
de nosotros
ahora sé que te estarás preguntando
bueno porque no la conectamos hacemos
que nos des la cura para muchas
enfermedades las ciudades futuristas la
tecnología de punta y luz le
desconectamos antes de que se vuelva
mala bueno
la respuesta es sencilla gracias a este
regalo de la biología es que somos
capaces no sólo de estar por sobre el
resto de los animales sino también somos
capaces de prever y de neutralizar
amenazas justo antes de que pase a
diferencia de los gorilas que cuando se
dieron cuenta que nosotros éramos un
riesgo ya estaban en jaulas nos
dedicamos a neutralizar y enjaular a
nuestro primo menos listo y menos capaz
ahora estamos en este punto clave de la
historia tratando de ver el futuro y de
proyectarlo viendo hacia el pasado todos
los inventos hasta este punto de la
humanidad dependían enteramente de
nosotros y es precisamente por eso que
podíamos mantenerlo dentro de los
confines de nuestros caprichos sin
embargo ya para este punto debía quedar
más que claro que tener un ente de
semejantes capacidades y dotarlo de
conciencia sería algo que se nos sale de
las manos
ahora será lo mejor creer que este ente
muy superior a nosotros esté bien siendo
nuestro sirviente
alan turing el padre de la computación
vio venir estoy en 1951
el veía venir que las computadoras no
nada más iban a ser capaces de exhibir
comportamiento inteligente o similar al
del ser humano sino que iban a llegar a
un punto muy superior en 1951 afirmó que
incluso si pudiésemos mantener a las
máquinas en una posición servil
utilizando para ello trucos baratos como
conectarla y desconectar la en momentos
estratégicos debemos sentirnos
grandemente humillados como especie
ahora si volvemos con bostróm bostróm
física el tener este ente con conciencia
este podría ser el último invento que la
humanidad tendría que hacer porque de
aquí en delante la inteligencia
artificial tomaría las riendas y sería
capaz de crear producir y destruir a
placer que podría salir mal
hay una razón por la cual tú y yo no
somos sirvientes de los gorilas a pesar
de que ellos son muy superiores a
nosotros físicamente porque gracias a
este regalo de la biología nos
mantenemos confinados en zoológicos pero
no hay una sola garantía de que nuestra
creación no quiere hacer lo mismo con
nosotros ahora algo así de capaz algo
así de listo y algo ha sido superior a
nosotros no puede ser contenido y menos
por nosotros es por eso que en el mejor
de los casos nos vamos a ver condenados
a coexistir o evolucionar sin embargo no
todo es malas noticias aquí este juego
de ajedrez nosotros tenemos la primera
jugada antes de mover ese primer peón
debemos de estar completamente seguros
de que las reglas y los parámetros están
dados de manera en la que no terminemos
en un zoológico para humanos
cómo hacemos inteligencia artificial
compatible con ser humano
weiner uno de los científicos más
reconocidos del siglo pasado solía decir
que el propósito que ponemos en las
máquinas debería de ser el propósito que
en realidad queremos se recapitula moss
los minutos el propósito de la
inteligencia artificial no es otro más
que número uno venir a subsanar todas
nuestras deficiencias y número dos
darnos la trascendencia que como especie
pedimos a gritos ese hijo a nuestra
imagen y semejanza para que aprenda lo
que es bello bueno y verdadero
por supuesto que crear una super
inteligencia supone un reto de origen
técnico y no lo menos presión pero el
reto de origen moral es todavía más
grande
no temo a la creación de la máquina
déjenme ser pintado temo a la creación
de la máquina ya cargar en ella toda la
decencia y las complicaciones propias de
la moralidad humana asistes y move a
bordo esto es un famosísimo yo robot
nuestra novela de futuro distópico cell
nos habla de las tres leyes de la
robótica y curiosamente lo complicado
que es para nosotros seguir las tres
leyes sencillas número uno no matarás
número 2 harás todo lo que un ser humano
te diga siempre y cuando no interfiera
con la primera regla y número 3 cuidarás
de tu propia existencia siempre y cuando
no interfiera con las leyes 1 y 2
sencillo no
ahora es complicado hablar de moralidad
porque incluso nosotros como especie
todavía no contamos con un sistema
homologado aún se discute acaloradamente
sobre si la deontología está por sobre
el utilitarismo o el pragmatismo es
mejor que cualquier otro código moral al
final de cuentas
incluso aunque pudiésemos crear una
inteligencia artificial con una sola
tarea es complicado
hoy en día se habla de inteligencia
artificial que venga a maximizar los
valores humanos pero tengo la pregunta
los valores humanos de quien los míos
los tuyos los de google los eeuu
la respuesta más sencilla y la más
cómoda para este tipo de cuestionamiento
siempre ha sido bueno pues que aprendan
de nosotros
pero tengo la pregunta aquí y ahora es
realmente lo mejor que aprenden de
nosotros
no te toma más de dos segundos darte
cuenta de que no que no somos el mejor
maestro para enseñarle lo que es bello
bueno verdadero porque como especie
somos los autores de muchos males muchos
errores y muchas mentiras pero tampoco
vengo a regañar a nadie si tenemos que
buscar un culpable a final de cuentas
ese sería nuestro origen la selección
natural nos enseñó a poner nuestro
bienestar nuestros valores y nuestras
creencias por sobre los demás y funcionó
perfecto aquí estamos siendo el
depredador aapex estando por sobre el
resto de todas las especies y sobre el
resto de todos los animales es
precisamente eso lo que nos hace
abogados perfectos de la justicia la
verdad lo bello bueno o verdadero
estamos aquí en un punto clave de la
historia tratando de burlar la
mortalidad y el olvido
tratando de burlar la muerte de manera
sublime con una obra perfecta pero
resulta que el molde no es tan perfecto
porque un molde con los valores y las
creencias humanas
no es así de perfecto
ahora la razón por la cual tú y yo nos
sentimos amos de todos y no nos sentimos
animales es porque nosotros a diferencia
del resto de las especies contamos con
un alma
es algo eterno indivisible y perfecto
esa chispa de humanidad de esa misma
chispa que nos llevó a regir el taj
mahal y tirar la bomba atómica a crear
las vacunas e inventar las bombas
químicas e inventar la escritura y
quemar la biblioteca de alejandría a
erigir la muralla china y tirar el muro
de berlín
por supuesto que maldad dentro de todos
nosotros por supuesto que hay vestigios
utilitarios del origen del ser humano
pero es precisamente dentro del alma y
dentro de sus horrores y maravillas que
podemos ver por un pequeño resquicio la
belleza y el misterio que la vida
engloba no
en este momento te puedo decir que
fallamos fallamos al crear a nuestra
obra maestra a nuestra imagen y
semejanza porque si le dimos capacidades
más allá de lo imaginable
le damos todo el cúmulo de información
que hemos recopilado como humanidad pero
estamos fallando al darle el factor
clave el alma como la vamos a poder
enseñar de los bellos bueno verdaderos y
jamás va a poder experimentar los
finalmente este viaje hacia nuestra obra
maestra representa retos de origen
técnico pero sobre todo de origen moral
porque en este punto de la historia nos
es imposible
bajar el alma humana reducirla a código
no puede reducir a código la dicha de un
padre al tomar a su hijo por primera vez
en brazos o el dolor de un hijo al
despedir a su padre no puede reducir a
código la gracia el amor la verdad del
horror ninguna de todas esas emociones
que nos hacen sentir vivos
lo que descubrimos cómo reducir el alma
humana código no nos queda de otra más
que hacer un viaje de introspección por
los pasillos del alma para que podamos
redescubrir y revivir todos los
misterios los horrores y las maravillas
que la vida implica es entonces y sólo
entonces que vamos a poder hablar de
nuestra obra maestra de nuestro hijo
prodigio es entonces y sólo entonces que
vamos a poder hablar de algo a nuestra
imagen y semejanza gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]